From Star Search to The Ellen DeGeneres
Show, Stephen "tWitch" Boss was a rare
talent and outgoing presence on
television for nearly two decades.
Despite lots of stories about how tWitch
got his name, claiming it was because he
never sat still as a kid, Boss himself told
AL.com in 2013 that he gave himself the name,
after a car he owned that "would accelerate
on its own sometimes." According to him,
he would come up with a lot of his choreography
while he was on the road to different performances
and teaching dance around the state of Alabama,
where he grew up. Boss told the outlet:
"I was about 20 years old ... when I first started
dancing, going places and teaching dance."
Before garnering a coveted spot on the
star-making show So You Think You Can Dance,
Stephen "tWitch" Boss competed in — and
nearly won — two other dance-related talent
competitions. Early in his dance career, tWitch
competed on the ubiquitous celebrity-magnet
talent show Star Search. Rebooted from the
original Ed McMahon juggernaut in 2003,
Star Search came back on the air to CBS with
host Arsenio Hall. It only lasted a year,
but in that time tWitch not only made
it on, but he was also the runner-up.
Also in 2003, tWitch competed on
MTV's The Wade Robson Project,
where dancers would battle against each other
for a grand prize of $100,000, making it to
the semifinals. Boss clearly remained a fan of
the legendary dancer and choreographer, as he
performed at least two solos to Robson's music
during his time on So You Think You Can Dance.
In that same interview, Boss
revealed that if he hadn't made
it onto So You Think You Can Dance,
he would've joined the Navy, saying,
"[E]verything I'm experiencing
now is because of the show."
It's not easy to get on So You Think You Can
Dance. First, there are auditions in cities
around the country for anyone and everyone
who thinks they can dance. A panel of judges,
generally made up of executive producer Nigel
Lythgoe and a selection of acclaimed industry
professionals, oversee the process. They
either give the contestant a pass straight
on to the next round in Las Vegas,
or they ask performers to come back
later that day for some structured
choreography for a second chance.
Las Vegas Week is grueling, as everyday
dancers are charged with learning a routine
from a star choreographer in a different genre
of dance, from hip-hop to jazz to ballroom to
contemporary. Only those who pass that entire
week will be up for consideration to compete
on the live shows. Boss auditioned in Season
3 but didn't make the cut. He was undeterred,
however, and in Season 4 he came back
and not only made it to the Top 20 but
was still standing in the finale,
finishing second to Joshua Allen.
Since then, he returned to So You
Think You Can Dance multiple times,
performing as a special guest or all-star, and
was part of dozens of unforgettable routines,
one of which even caught the eye of a certain
Ellen DeGeneres, leading to a new opportunity.
In 2010, Fox aired Season 7 of the popular dance
competition So You Think You Can Dance. The
seventh season was the first to feature All-Stars,
in which popular contestants from previous seasons
would pair with the new dancers competing
for the current title. It was here that Boss,
a contestant and runner-up from Season 4,
met Allison Holker, a standout talent from
Season 2. Allison was instantly attracted
to Stephen, as she insisted on calling him,
and made the first move, as she told Jennifer
Hudson on the latter's daytime talk show.
"You know, I was out there making
all these moves and it took him a
second to see them but once he did, you
know, we locked it in. We locked it in."
Boss eventually "locked it down," though,
and the couple married in 2013. Since then,
their fairytale marriage has been followed
by millions of fans on TikTok and Instagram,
has produced two children, and even got them
a hosting gig on Disney's Fairy Tale Weddings,
showcasing mega Disney fans getting
married at one of the resort's many
properties. Upon announcing her
husband's death, Holker promised:
"I will always save the last dance for you."
Before his revealing role in Magic Mike XXL
as a male exotic dancer in a ladies' club,
Stephen "tWitch" Boss racked up several dance
credits in films over the years. It all started
in 2006 when he had a small, uncredited role as
"flamboyant dancer" in Blades of Glory. Following
that, tWitch appeared as one of Mama Maybelle's
dancers in the Adam Shankman musical reboot of
Hairspray. Rounding out his resumé with Stomp
the Yard 2: Homecoming and installments three,
four, and five of the Step Up franchise, tWitch
built a steady career out of and about dance.
Even in his cameo role on the TV series
Bones, he appeared as a street performer,
dancing for the passersby and hoping
for a few bucks in his proffered hat.
Stephen Boss was a man meant to dance, and
when he met Allison Holker they seemed to
speak in a language of dance all their
own. He proposed to her through dance.
They announced their first pregnancy together
through dance. They performed together on
Dancing with the Stars when Allison worked
there as one of the pros. They celebrated
Allison's ninth month of pregnancy with
their second baby via a motivating dance,
and they warmed the hearts of followers
with family and friend dances on TikTok.
It's not often that a celebrity can reach so many
people and resonate so strongly with their best
dreams and hopes for the world, but Stephen
"tWitch" Boss was one of those men. He will
be missed in every community that treasured his
unique combination of dance, laughter, and warmth.
If you or anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts, please call the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline​ by dialing 988
or by calling 1-800-273-TALK (8255)​.